avon mouth on the river seven
flooding is a part of life here but it's
getting worse
that's why the government's chosen this
place to announce how it's going to
spend
billions of pounds on flood protection
schemes across the country
this is to better protect our homes our
communities our businesses
and make us more resilient to climate
change we know we're going to get more
extreme weather events
we need to be prepared for them despite
the influx of cash
eventually hard decisions will have to
be made about who and what
is protected from the rising water
roughly
one in every five households
is at risk of flooding there may come a
time in the future
where as part of that building back
better we need to consider whether we
move to better places where the risk
of flooding is reduced
global warming is reshaping our world in
other ways too
in terms of sheer destructive power rain
and flooding
often grabs the headlines in the uk but
climate change is also
driving up our temperatures at the met
office headquarters in exeter
they've been tracking some worrying
patterns this is where operational
meteorologists
senior climate scientist mike kendon has
just written a report
revealing that 2020 was the first year
since records began
to rank in the top 10 for heat rainfall
and sunshine climate change isn't just
something that's going to happen in the
future
climate change is something that is
happening now we see that very clearly
in our observations
the royal meteorological society has
warned that even a small increase in
global warming
could mean british summertime
temperatures reaching 40 degrees
in this country the race to adapt to the
effects of climate change
has only just begun hannah thomas peter
sky news aven mouth